after was forced to close its doors
vicky's diner reopens tomorrow in a new
location the iconic restaurant stood as
one of the oldest and best known in town
dating back to the 1950s on the las
vegas strip
hector mejia tells us where they're
headed this new location is not too far
away from the las vegas strip it's here
at the commercial center off sahara
just about a five minute drive away from
the original location
it's taken almost a year to get here
but it was worth the wait the
resurrected vicky's diner is almost
three times bigger
than the original one i'll be honest
with you i want to cry
and it's mixed feelings mixed feelings
good feelings
people support me all the time
and i'm going to continue to take care
of everyone
it was the oldest diner inside the old
white cross pharmacy on las vegas
boulevard
north of sahara vicki calesis is the
owner she says she had to move out in
august of 2020
the property sold back in its early days
it was a late night favorite for locals
and big entertainers including elvis
presley
always orders techniques
and liberating even sinatra
a lot of celebrities this place is known
around the world because of media
coverage
and customer loyalty let's talk about
hours it will be open
seven days a week for breakfast and
lunch from 6 a.m
to 2 30 p.m hector mejia reporting 8
news now